America absolutely has a why and we are
so lucky unlike so many other places in
the world because our founding fathers
wrote it down for us we literally have a
document that explains why we needed our
own country in fact we declared it we
declared our independence and we said
that we want to have our own country
because we have a simple belief that
belief is that all men are created equal
and we're endowed with these unalienable
rights life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and what I absolutely love is
that when we are at our natural best we
are pursuing that ideal it's funny
because we're always talking about the
Constitution this and the Constitution
that the Constitution is a structural
document it lays out the structure on
how we will achieve our why and how we
will actually achieve this ideal this
idealized state of what the world could
be like it's actually the Declaration of
Independence we should be wrapping
ourselves in because every time we're at
our best were pursuing that now
Democrats and Republicans will interpret
differently the path to take to that but
at the end of the day there's no
difference between a Democrat and a
Republican it's just the manner in which
they choose to interpret the path we
take to achieve the ideal that is
perfectly written down for us in the
Declaration of Independence it's one of
my favorite favorite why documents in
the world